The importance of quantum computing is both understated
and wildly over-hyped at the same time.
Although it won't replace conventional computers
quantum innovation represents a new computing paradigm.
Quantum computers can work in unison with current computing
infrastructure to solve complex problems that were previously
thought impractical or impossible.
This can be paradigm-shifting.
For example the difficulty of factoring large numbers
into their primes is the basis of modern
cryptography. For the size of numbers used in modern public
private key encryption this calculation would take
the fastest conventional computer over 300 trillion years.
For a large-scale quantum computer working
with Shor's algorithm this calculation could take seconds.
Complex problems like this exist across all industries.
The potential applications for quantum computing
are vast.
Quantum computers are already growing larger
and more capable,
as we aim to tackle more complicated problems.
Since 2016, IBM has made quantum computers accessible
to the public via a website with a graphical interface that
looks like a musical score.
and the software development kit Qiskit
which allows users to program quantum computers.
Scientists inside an outside the corporate world
are running experiments
via similar portals. They're exploring approaches to chemistry
and machine learning problems trying to figure out
what sorts of questions they can ask
and how they'll frame those questions
once the technology is further along. Now is the
right time for business leaders to prepare
for quantum. The conditions are in place to experiment
and expand this fundamentally new technology.
Organizations that seek to be at the
forefront of this transformational shift will
seize competitive advantage. This training
will prepare you to start your quantum journey!